I think that this year is a very important
year because the Davos meeting is happening
in not a very conventional way because everybody
astonishes at crisis but also everybody is
trying to think how we can it-this crisis.
And one of the opportunities that's happening
right now is the crisis help us to think and
which are the fastest ways to go in the direction
of a low carbon economy. And I think that
in several speeches here we can see the commitment
of several leaders and-and statesmans towards
the commitment with climate change and action
in the direction of a new type of a _____
economy.
And the second thing that I think is very
important is rethinking ethic in business.
More and more we have to have transparency,
collaboration and the lessons learned from
the crisis help us to understand that the
real next step after the crisis will be a
much more committed economy to ethics and
values that can support trust.